today men know the seven as statues in
the septs but in the old days the gods
themselves walked among men they crowned
Hyuga of the hill the first king of the
Andal and promised him that his
descendants would rule great kingdoms in
a foreign continent when the time came
the Andals carved the seven pointed star
upon their bodies and set sail for the
strange land across the Narrow Sea
Westeros whilst ándale warriors battled
the first men for kingdoms and
acceptance battled for souls and were
received
just as courteously we don't know how
many bold and pious men lost their lives
but adversity bred strength our purest
and most righteous believers took up the
sword to defend and preserve the faith
from its enemies so was born the order
of the faith militant when Aegon the
conquerer landed in Westeros the High
Septon locked himself in a Sept for
seven days and seven nights finally the
Crone lifted her golden lamp and showed
him the path ahead the High Septon
himself would anoint and crown Aegon as
Lord of the Seven Kingdoms and the faith
militant rallied behind a ger in
governing his newly united land yet
Aegon and his sisters never wholly
accepted the faith the High Septon had
conceded Aegon's marriages to his
sisters as a relic of his Valyrian
heritage which would soon fade
but when Aegon zaire where'd his
daughter to his son the faith could
brook such abomination no longer the
High Septon led the denunciation of the
Targaryens and all over Westeros the
faith militant took up their swords
against the dynasty and its supporters
the faith militant set upon and punished
the Septon who had performed the
ceremony a few of the faith militants
more militant members even scaled the
walls of the castle and would have slain
the king and his family had a knight of
the Kingsguard not intervened
frightened the King fled to Dragonstone
where he soon died of cramps and so
ascended the Kings younger brother
maegor the cruel his first act was to
challenge the faith militant to kill him
if they believed his rule to be ungodly
to the orders eternal credit they
accepted ser Damon Morrigan proposed a
trial by seven said Damon and six of the
faith militant against the king and his
six champions it was a contest in which
the kingdom itself was at stake and the
accounts and tales are many but at the
end of it make or alone lived proving
that the throne was rightfully his he
mounted the black dragon balerion and
burnt down the Sept in King's Landing
while the faith militant were inside at
morning prayers the screams of the
burning and dying men were said to echo
throughout the city vomega had won the
trial by seven he demanded the complete
destruction of the faith militant and
the faith itself if necessary he made
war upon the order wherever he found it
yet the faith militant were not
surrender raising armies of their own
and turning Megas own lords against him
the father's justice may not always be
Swift but it is certain
one morning mega was found dead on the
Iron Throne
no one knows how Makos cruelty died with
him his successor saw the wisdom of a
United crown and faith and his hand
reached an accord with the High Septon
as long as the Iron Throne defended the
faith the faith would put aside its own
swords and its condemnation of the
Targaryen s' perhaps the High Septon
felt he had no course but compromised
outlawed and hunted for years the faith
militant was but a shadow of its former
self without its own Guardians the faith
would have to rely on corrupt worldly
kings and their corrupt worldly courts
for thousands of years the faith
militant had stood watch over the faith
and then its son said now after years of
war and destruction of abomination and
blasphemy none can argue that we have
been walking through darkness perhaps
the time has come when the Sun must rise
again
you